doing what you love to do doing what you
love to do is the way that you're going
to give the best to the world and for me
my brand is about the live performance
it's about touring it's about you know
coming out here and and hopes in these
parties and having fun touching the
people what she makes is he's an
American recording artist and record
producer from Washington DC he's
produced hit singles for a number of
prominent artists in a variety of genres
he's also the founder and CEO of
superphone and next selection lifestyle
group
he's Ryan Leslie and here is my take on
his top 10 rules for success
rule number 10 is my personal favorite
also as Ryan is talking if he says
something that's really meaningful to
you please leave it in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
at 15 years old you went to Harvard
scored 1,600 on the SAT directors
graduated at 19 and at 19 when you gave
the commencement speech at Harvard you
said that you wanted to be a performer
and some people laughed tell me about
that well I mean you just have to think
you know after four years and a $120,000
worth that fact you know arguably one of
the greatest education that the world
has to offer at Harvard there's so many
other opportunities and pathways that
you could take as a young bright and
even an african-american you know
there's like oh man you know there's
already so many african-americans that
want to rap or that you know they want
to make music like you know why can't we
have an incredible um you know outlier
like it we have someone who's you know
an incredible spokesperson or we can
have another Barack Obama so to speak
you know and for me it always once again
comes back to what we touched on before
which is doing what you love to do doing
what you love to do is the way that
you're going to give the best to the
world and I knew that anything else that
I did whether it was you know taking a
job at Boston Consulting Group or you
know even the community service and
philanthropy initiatives in which I was
involved you know I have a passion for
those things but none of them even
remotely touches the passion that I have
for live performance and music
harmer because guess what the life that
I live
going from country to country saying his
name to music video in studio seemed
like everywhere I go people ask me Brian
how can I get that life the only way I
was able to do was by working harder
than everyone else who said they wanted
it but didn't work hard enough to get my
were invites are really the same words
that I spoke on when I was a teenager
and I needed money for college and so I
hinted a speech competition for Rotary
International and the the the topic that
the apps' asked me to speak on was do
what you believe in and believe in what
you do and even now 12 years later when
I look around that's what I strive to do
every day do what I believe in and
believe in what I do and for everyone
out there that has an aspiration to do
something don't let anyone tell you what
you can and cannot do if you got a dream
and a goal and a passion to do it you
know I can't tell you the amount of
people that told me like look Ryan stick
to stand behind the synthesizer or if
you're gonna sing don't try to rap or if
you rap don't try to sing or if you
produce don't try to be an artist or if
you if you if you if you're R&B dude
don't try to go into the the rock or
alternative side or if you don't dance
don't try to dance or if you dance don't
you know don't don't decide that you're
just going to stay behind the keyboard
really for me I think artistry the
beauty and the joy of artistry and the
beauty and the joy of just having the
freedoms that we enjoy in life is that
we can pursue anything that we want to
pursue and with the right mix of Drive
desire discipline and dedication we can
achieve anything that we want to achieve
and so for all y'all out there that have
a dream I encourage you to keep striving
pushing forward towards that dream and
make it happen man there's a lot of rap
artists or hip-hop artists you know or
urban music artists that go overseas and
they just assume that you know it's a
privilege for that market to have them
and they don't really deliver on all in
terms of a live experience you know they
come over they might give a half an hour
show 40-minute show they do it to track
they go out there then collect the money
because there's good money out there and
then come home and because they're
touring bases in the States
they leave a lot of fans really
disappointing you know and it's been my
strategy to go out there and really just
shatter anyone elses live performance at
least at the level that I'm doing it
right now we're doing like 1,200 to
2,000 Cedars
you know maybe 3,000 on in some market
and really just shatter everyone's
expectations about what egotism you know
an American artist might have by coming
out here and we built an incredible
toilet base you know we honestly if you
average it out we're doing probably 1.2
million dollars a month in Europe you
know if we go out there for a month so
that's that's 40,000 tickets at 35 euros
a ticket top-line you know you do the
math also we're the new project you plan
to release each song if you do
absolutely for free
absolutely so why'd you take this major
event
music well I mean really if you look at
the economics of the music business
right now you really making money when
you're on the road and when you're toy
and so it's like it's like like have you
ever paid to download a coca-cola
commercial no have you ever paid to
download a commercial for a car no so
all the money that they spend in
creating an advertisement for just a can
of coke or pepsi I mean the Super Bowl
to salmon in the United States all the
big advertisements the amount of money
that they spent to create those
advertisements you're watching it for
free and what it really is it's a call
to action for you to buy into the brand
and for me my brand is about the lack
performance it's about touring it's
about you know coming out here and and
and hopes in these parties and having
fun touching the people and so when
people are paying back just you just
really have to think when someone pays
$20 to come to the club that's double
the price of an ounce you know and they
might do that three or four times a year
as opposed to just buying your album one
time for $10 so I'm looking at this as
an advertisement for Ryan Leslie the
brand Ryan Leslie just the personality
because I like to come out you know some
suckers you're just yours
Jumma Dibley off
SiC bus go I want to be able to touch
the people and I want people to have a
reason to want to come in in a rush with
me yes I look at it that way because I'm
planning future king normal around our
Roxy diesel I would say they're very few
artists that actually even make money
from record sales right because the
record labels have given them in advance
and they only make money when they do
shows how to do appearances or to sell
t-shirts we got the NS for life hoodies
you look at my mail after you get
bananas for life later you know that
that's that's it's something that you
can't download that experience you can't
download and I'm not stupid
yeah I know what's going on I mean you
know when you look at the streaming
services when you look at the
file-sharing services people are going
to share your stuff anyway it's digital
you know whether it's a photograph or a
song so the concert experience that's
something that you can't download you
know either you have a ticket to the
jay-z concert or you just at home you
know I mean you can't download that
experience so my interest in making an
album with all the visuals and all the
music is to create a demand for that
concert experience that you can tell so
you're not strictly an artist you're a
businessman yeah but what what could you
really say in terms of handling your
business in an economy like this do
you'll really have to focus on these
days you know because I think very few
people who are watching this right now
could really say you know I'm good for
ten years financially yeah you know I
most people are living paycheck to
paycheck once a month they may have a
little bit savings but they're not
sitting on a decade's worth of living
expenses yeah well it also depends on on
what your living expenses are you know I
live within my means you know I mean so
so that's the first thing the first
thing is you got to live within your
means yeah you know so if you if you if
you decide that you know
and I and I have friends that decide
they want to be in the penthouse before
they can afford to really be in the
penthouse but they can afford to be in
the penthouse for a year maybe so they
go and do that for a year I mean and to
each their own everybody has the
prerogative to live however they want to
live so we're not promised tomorrow so a
lot of people who just have the idea hey
let me live for today you know it's all
until I fall yeah you know and so it's
all good I mean for me it's just about
just being responsible and cognizant of
what you need to be happy you know
and so for me all I need is the ability
to keep creating okay and I'm good the
first time I met you you told me that
this when you were a producer for bad
boy and you told me that Tommy Mottola
and puffy used to always tell you you
why do you want to be an artist you're
hustling backwards right what do they
mean by that and why did you persist to
continue to become an artist well I
think they really being the luminaries
that they are and the moguls that they
are um you know they were talking much
more in terms of just the generation of
income and for me generating income in a
way that you know is just left of center
of what you love to do it's not the way
I want to live you know and I feel like
the American Dream which is you know
what I really consider myself the
embodiment of I thought the American
Dream is being able to make a living
doing what you love to do and so for me
production was always just a stepping
stone to amass enough money so that
eventually as the music industry shifted
I could buy my contract out and reinvest
all the money that I had earned into
doing what I really love to do which is
being on stage playing and you know just
going running around the world and
playing shows for screaming audiences
all over the world
people usually make it two ways radio
television and 2010 there's a new way is
called in right you too but so what she
make you stuff once you make your stuff
put yourself out there so people can
hear enough people respond I give you
three examples sociable
and also
and also the Guyanese you see sitting
right here if someone's a true fan they
will actually you know they'll let you
know with their opinions but at the end
of the day it's entertainment so if they
don't want to listen to what I'm talking
about they're just playing on people I
mean just go search youtube rmz singers
so you can go find a whole bunch of R&B
singers but if you like what I do which
is just being as honest as I can be and
you know making the records from scratch
I mean that's really that's really where
I have the biggest fan base right it is
from the YouTube videos of me in the
studio
so nothing about that has changed at all
I mean I'm still in studio making the
songs from scratch and you know I have a
different perspective I have a different
life experience that I'm writing from
I'm going to say an affirmation and at
the end of the affirmation I will ask
Who am I and you will respond I'm a
Harlem gen Who am I
that's right now I understand that
obstacles are really opportunities to
learn and to grow stronger so when I am
met with the challenge I will rise to
the occasion and I will do my best to
set an example of perseverance of
persistence and of discipline for my
community Who am I
that's right now I might not have all
the money in the world
but I do understand that I have the same
24 hours in a day as anyone else and so
in the interests of becoming great I
have no problem making the commitment to
invest more of my time and becoming the
best representation of myself that I
could be Who am I now I understand that
whether I'm on the field or off the
field the same principles of love
teamwork fairness and collaboration I
understand that those principles apply
in my everyday life and I will do the
best that I can to treat others with the
same respect with which I want to be
treated and do the same for our
environment as well Reema
now I understand that no matter where I
am today no matter the struggles that
are going through well that my family is
going through
no matter what my world looks like today
the
that I won't live in tomorrow will be
the world that I created and I would
never allow anyone to keep me from
pursuing my dreams I love life I love my
family I love my community and I love my
country
Who am I Who am I
god bless you all god bless follow me
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because pearl ponds
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know what did Ryan say that left the
biggest mark on you what change you're
going to make now after watching this
video leave it down in the comments by
writing it you'll solidify your intent
to actually follow through on it and
hopefully inspire other people as well
so leave in the comments I will join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shadow to Paulette from totally
inspired mine calm Paulette bought 10
copies of my book thank you so much it
really really really means a lot to me
thanks again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon